now the important thing that I came to
realize in the course of my life is that
the Christian escort on is something
utterly different so much so that in a
sense they are anti-portal
why
the the key is
every Christian knows that was the
church fathers used to say God became
man so that man can become God but so
yes who says that the fathers
uh
I mean
it was assumed Saint Augustine or Saint
Thomas Aquinas they all would have
agreed with that who actually spoke
these words I'm not enough of a scholar
too but it's a formula that is accepted
in Christianity as Orthodox
God became man so that man can become
God
but to be more precise
the
the way of knowing god or seeing God
that is offered to us by Christianity in
contrast to the vedantic way is that by
becoming a member of the mystical Body
of Christ through baptism
we are able to see God the Father
through Christ the son
through the Incarnate Christ uh
without the Incarnation there would be
no such possibility but
this is why God became man
to form a bridge as it were between the
human and the Divine and through that
bridge
we can come to God the Father through
God the son and more specifically the
Incarnate son there is a distinction
between Christ as the second person of
the Holy Trinity and Christ as we
worship him in our churches because what
we worship and
what otherwise could not really be
worshiped is God in the form of man this
is a crucial point
so through Christianity a new escort on
was given to Mankind and the interesting
thing is that in Vedic days
that did not exist that became a reality
when Christ was born on Earth
and that is long after
The Vedic period had begun
so there the the sadhus in India were
practicing their vedanta the long before
there was a Christianity
so that began with the birth of Christ
and it ended it was completed with a
resurrection
and we are
we are part of that
uh we belong to that past our past is
not the direct pass which is practiced
in vedanta our passes through the God
man
and incidentally there's a wonderful
passage in
the gospel of Saint John
which speaks very directly to this it is
taken from the what is traditionally
called the
um
Priestly
the high Priestly prayer Discord so it
is
before the passion when Christ went into
this Garden
to pray
he said
addressing God the father he said
this is life eternal
to Know Thee
the only true God in Jesus Christ who
was sent
this says it all
coming from the mouths of God himself
this says it all in other words our
approach
to
salvation
to the union with God is through Jesus
Christ who was sent these are the actual
words of Jesus
and when he says who was sent
is a direct reference to the Incarnation
in other words there would be there
could be no Christianity no other path
to God Than The Vedic if it were not for
the Incarnation It Is by God becoming
man
that this other path was born
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy